hello everyone and welcome to the moment
you've all been waiting for its Jose
raúl capablanca versus Emanuel Lasker
Dean negotiations it's gonna take up
quite a bit of your time so I do hope
you have your popcorn ready and that you
are prepared to get to get into this as
it's really complicated and insane I
like I mentioned in my previous video
and sorry about the the the sound of the
Meuse was off in the previous video but
I have no idea what's the reason behind
this so I hope it will improve until my
next video now going into the
negotiations like we mentioned first
kappa blanka in this saga has a defeated
one course or champion of cuba then he
defeated with an outstanding result
Frank James Marshall one of the top
considered to be the one of the top 10
players in the world with a result of
eight wins and only one loss then cup of
lanka went to his first big
international tournament of san
sebastian in 1911 and he defeated it
half a point ahead of dr. emil and
Widmer and Akiba Rubinstein even though
he did lose that one game to akiba
Rubinstein but in the end he capablanca
prevailed and all of this culminated in
the Capablanca boost in confidence to
challenge dr. emmanuel a score for the
title and often Blancas friends or or
family or even the newspapers the public
general public would ask a cup of monka
prior to the 911 tournament of San
Sebastiano would he challenge dr. Lasker
for the title and he said that he was
still not cross swords with the champion
as he still does not consider himself
ready but like I said this seems like a
fair boost in confidence and Capablanca
has offered a challenge to dr. Lasker
but before we get into that first we
need to understand that in those days
for example in 1911 there was no chess
organization like fidei exists the day
there was no governing body that would
organize events like the World Chess
Championship and so the players pretty
much did it between themselves
Capablanca would issue a challenge to
dr. last for Lasker would reply all four
terms and if the terms were agreed upon
the
would happen but it wasn't always so
smooth for example you all know that
when Paul Morphy was considered the
strongest player in the world
he won the first American chess congress
which was attended by pretty much every
every strongest chess player in the
world
aside from Howard Stanton and Otto
Fenderson but then a Morphy traveled and
met dr. Ralph Anderson and he defeated
out of Anderson with a very nice result
he did not play Howard Stanton but
Stanton was ill I guess or so he said
but still pretty much everyone in the
world considered to pull more feet to be
the world champion as often you will
hear that Paul Morphy is the first
unofficial world chess champion but then
after you know I think things started
moving more if you retired from chess
then Johannes 2/4 defeated Adolph
Anderson and then he was supposed to
play against William Stein it's for the
title of first official world champion
even though there was no God like I said
no official body that would present
William Stein it's with such a title
would he win this match and if you
remember Steinem said that if morphe was
to unretire from chess that he would
much rather play morphe for the title
than johannes to court but morphe wasn't
interested so Chinese beat Sacher Torte
and Chinese became the first official
world champion even though when we say
official there still was no badge on
shiny toe or any how to put any document
that said that Stannis was the official
world champion much like today Magnus
Carson is defeated world champion but if
some of you I don't know created a
second Organization for chest like as
part of did his professional chess
Association then Magnus Carlsen would
still be defeated World Chess Champion
but someone who won a tournament in your
organization would be your world's
champion as such was the case so like I
said Spanish was the champion in the
minds of people and in in the opinions
of the general public and when Alaska
defeated William Stein its then Alaska
became world champion but he didn't
receive any official document stating
that dr. Lasker was now world
and so when capablanca issued the
challenge Papa Blanca first selected a
we could say illegal representative it
was Frederick D Roosevelt gentlemen we
don't know much about I have found on
chess history calm an article by Edward
winter you can fight it find it it will
be the first thing in the description
below so you can read something more
about him he was all also capablanca
business associate and he was the one
that presented dr. Lasker with a letter
with the challenge from josé raúl
capablanca dr. Lasker received it on 4th
of November in the art room of the
Brooklyn Institute of Arts and Sciences
and he replied to Capablanca that he
generally accepts the challenge but he
cannot so hastily grant him the terms of
such such an event so he will have to
wait for Alaska to reply and some two
weeks have passed and Alaska has
presented the terms of the World Chess
Championship match between Alaska and
capablanca and here are the terms I
present I present them to you via the
book about Capablanca by edward winter
these are the terms as you can see there
are 17 of them and we are going to go
through all of them as it's quite
important for you to really grasp the
magnitude of this match so ok let's go
we have ended they were issued in
Evening Post column so won the match to
be six games up draws not counting but
should neither of the contestants have
scored six points after 30 games have
been completed the match to end it them
so you either have to be up six points
in a match to win it immediately or if
the match lasts for 30 games then the
match is over and then if no one has
achieved such a thing then the game will
the match will be drawn and in the
second point you see the first winner of
six games to win the match as we already
said if the match should extend the 30
games he who has heard scored the
majority of points to beat the winner of
the match except when the score should
be 1 to 0 2 to 1 or 3 to 2 in these
cases as well as in case of equality of
points the match to be declared the
drawn and this point was the
biggest remark of a bunker had in
regards to to last curse terms about the
match it basically means that Capablanca
has to win by a margin more larger than
one point so if the result is kappa
blanka wins one game and the other 29
games are drawn Alaska you know keeps
his title also if the result is cover
Blanca wins two games Alaska wins one
and other 27 games are drawn Alaska
still keeps his title also here you see
if it's three to two
so capablanca wins three games large
score wins two games the other 25 games
are drawn then also Alaska keeps the
title only if capablanca for example
wins four games Alaska wins three games
it's still a one-point margin but in
this case Lasker says okay in this case
even if all the other games are drawn
you would win the title and the
Capablanca did not did not enjoy this
kappa blanka answered the alaska also
via letter we are public letter then it
was not on these terms that Alaska won
the title from Stannis and it was not on
these terms that Lasker has well at
least
for what we know has defended his title
so far so in couple Blancas opinion if
kapalama
capablanca wins the match by a one-point
margin he is the champion because okay
in other sports if you win by one point
margin you're still the winner it would
be a couple blanca says that it would be
unfair to claim that okay blanca won the
match but only by a one-point margin so
even though he's the better player
Alaska is still world champion it
doesn't really make much sense but
Lasker then again really replied in a
letter saying that it would be it would
be ashamed that for example Alaska loses
the first game and then kappa blanka
forcefully draws the other 29 games so
it's Oscar says that it's kind of a
assurance that the games will be
interesting not only for them but also
for for the viewers and you know it
would be bad for chess if such a rule
was to be allowed but it's you know he's
the title holder so of course he wants
and Capablanca has to have at least the
two-point margin and
Blanka wants a fair fight I mean it's
it's like that it's when you don't have
a governing body and let's do people you
know brawl it out then we have the point
three the winner of the match to be
declared chess champion of the world and
to receive the total stakes in case of a
drone issue doctor Alaska retains the
title of champion and the stakes are
returned to the backers Capablanca
answered that in his letter that he has
nothing you know no remarks about to
this point if the first two points are
fixed and Capablanca only needs one win
to actually win by one point margin to
win the match then we go into four and
as you can see in for the games of the
match are the property of dr. Lasker who
is at liberty to charge for the viewing
of them and for their publication in any
form may he deemed to his advantage so
basically it means that if even if
capablanca wins the match and he becomes
world champion the games
the moves of the games the pga ends we
could say are the property of emmanuel
Lasker and he can charge for them as
much as he likes so even if Capablanca
were to write a book and he would like
to present the games that he played
against last spring that book he would
have to pay Lasker for such a privilege
as the games would be property of dr.
Emmanuel Lasker also Capablanca had
remarks about this he said that to
create a game you need two players so
it's not a lost game it's a creation of
to two people so last we cannot have the
sole privilege of charging money for
viewership and for publication but on
the other hand cup of blood then Alaska
real replied to Capablanca that it's
Lasker who is the world champion he has
been the world champion for over twenty
years now and that people are interested
in his games and that he doesn't need
kappa blanka too young to spark the
public's interest he could play against
any opponent and people would still be
very much interested because it's
emmanuel a square that's playing and
okay
we have as you can see six dr. Lasker
has the right to determine the beginning
of the match and the locality of play he
shall however give mister Capablanca at
least four weeks notice
of the time set for the beginning and at
least two weeks notice for
change of locality couple uncle said
that okay
generally that that's fine but he said
that four weeks is much to a little over
time in advance he says that okay this
is not maybe if we're going get going a
bit too far
but if Lasker said okay we're gonna play
in Australia then I guess four weeks is
not enough notice for a couple blanca
soca blanc is just making sure that none
of these points are to his complete
disadvantage so kappa blanka says that
he will accept if alaska would notify
him three months in advance and okay
about changing venues one month in
advance and Lasker said that again in in
a letter that he replies that he does
not agree to these terms that if such a
such an occasion would happen work up a
Blanc would really have to travel really
far that more time would be allowed but
the
capablanca really wants everything to be
you know clear and Lasker Alaska does it
with wit honor it would seem he's the
world champion he wouldn't do anything
to compromise the quality of the match
mister Capablanca to deposit two
thousand dollars with the stake holder
as a guarantee that he will deposit the
stakes at the appointed time the
guarantee to be wholly forfeited to dr.
Lasker if mr. kappa blanka after
promising to deposit his share of the
stakes at the appointed time does not do
so Capablanca also says that this is a
bit too much because when Lasker played
against Williams Chinese he didn't have
to deposit two thousand dollars as you
know as a safeguard but rather two
hundred and fifty dollars and it's time
it's also deposited the same so
Capablanca says okay last Cronos
Capablanca can raise more money than
than any any other challenger but still
if capablanca is to raise $2,000 then
alaska also has to put up $2,000 like
chinese had to put up two hundred and
fifty dollars in in their match and okay
number 8 we have actually dr. Lasker not
deposit the stakes agreed upon or should
he fail to name the locality of the
match within a year from present date
mister kappa blanka is to be declared
the chess champion of the world and the
stakes the posture shall be returned to
the backers palanca says that this
number 8 is pointless
as capablanca does not wish to be named
the champion of the world
without a fair fight as the public would
not consider him world champion he would
be just someone unworthy of the title as
you all know a similar thing happened to
Anatoly Karpov when he won the title
without facing Bobby Fischer and he had
to prove himself for years and years to
come
okay people knew knew that he was strong
but still everyone was always but is he
stronger than Fischer hmm
so the kappa blanka has right idea here
you have to beat the champion to become
champion number nine the time limit
shall be 12 moves an hour and this is
also one of the points that capablanca
really hated Capablanca said that this
is not the time control that you use to
defeat will huge Chinese you play the
ball how much tennis at 15 moves an hour
so by playing at 12 moves an hour it's a
much slower time control and he said
that you also when you negotiate it with
the universe key and also when you are
negotiated with Frank James Marshall
it was also 15 moves per hour so not 12
and Capablanca says it's unfair because
Lasker is world champion at 15 moves per
hour
at that time control not at 12 moves per
hour and it would be unfair if Lasker
could choose different time controls
when he faces different opponents it
would be like Magnus Carlsen would now
say to the Caruana in their match I
don't think we'll be playing classical
it will will immediately play bullets
and may the best man win not really
something you you'd want to do but on
the other hand there are players that
I'm sure Carlsen wouldn't mind playing
classical games at all
so definitely Capablanca said that
that's out of the question but in a real
reply to that point
Oscar said that 12 points 12 moves per
hour would create much better games
because because at 15 moves per hour
players would suffer under time pressure
and the quality of the games would be
much lower but we also need to look at
number 9 and number 10 to really
understand this because at number 9
Oscar says that the time limit shall be
12 moves an hour and then the the plate
to proceed and no oftener than 5 days
per week each play data consists of 2
sections of two hours and a half each
one in the afternoon and the one at
night and Capablanca says that this is a
if number nine and number ten would be
agreed upon then you would basically
have a really slow game if you would
play 12 moves an hour and if a session
would be only two and a half hour before
rest and then two and a half hour in the
evening that you would basically reach
18 moves 17 18 moves in the first part
of the game then you would go rest you
know just chill and basically it would
not be a contest between two two players
a champion and a challenger it would be
an analytical contest because during the
first 17 moves of the game you you would
barely reach any position that was not
previously known so it would still be in
the opening and after the position is
reached then Alaska would have a lot of
time during his break and before
continuation of the game in the evening
to analyze the game and then it would be
much harder to do so capablanca suggests
that we should play 15 moves per hour
and that sessions should last six hours
so no breaks before a session of six
hours there you would have so at least
90 moves would be played basically an
entire game can be played during this
time but you know it's again you don't
have a governing body to to move these
these negotiations forward you have
Alaska who is much older and the cub
Blanca who is 23 years of age at this
moment are pretty much the same as last
girl was when he played Chinese for the
title but okay we're gonna get back to
this to umpires to be named a1 for the
United States the other one for Europe
in case of need an umpire residing in
the South America or in Cuba to be named
also if any dispute arises between the
contestants the nearest one of these
umpires is to be appealed to in writing
he who protests to forward a copy of his
claim to the defendant who shall put in
his defense in writing forwarding a copy
of it to the to the claimant Carver
Lanka says that he has no nothing
against this the play shall be governed
by a director of play who shall be in
possession
of a coach to be agreed upon at the game
to be viewed by the seconds of the
players who shall be appealed to - for
evidence in all cases of dispute the
director of play to decide all disputes
relating to the playing of the game and
to the code again Capablanca did not
have anything against this since the
stakes played for in the former matches
were insufficient to compensate the
players the two principals agreed to
raise the stakes to the higher level mr.
Campo Blanca to wire a wire dr. Lasker
the amount of his backing no later than
two months from the date of this letter
and dr. Laster to determine the amount
of the stakes no later than two months
from the date of receipt of mr.
Capablanca Swire just a second
kappa blanka says that he generally
doesn't mind this as he knows last we
know that he's able to raise the money
as he had a cup of anger can muster up a
lot of backers but that he should know
upfront the amount that Capablanca has
to has to accumulate because yes when
Lasker faced shine it's the the quality
of living was much lower and the money
raised was not enough for forward Chess
Championship match so here we can
understand Lasker's idea he wants to
gain as the most out of this match as
possible but still capablanca wants
everything to be as detailed as possible
so if one of the contestants is unable
to put in an appearance at the time
appointed for play for any reason
whatsoever the game shall begin at the
appointed time nevertheless as if the
players were both present and the time
limit rule shall be applied also in the
absence of one of the players here
couple monka says that okay I mean it's
it's pretty steep I mean if you break
your leg or I mean if someone let's say
stabs you with knife you should be
excused from the game but in Lasker's
opinion or end in last great words
Lasker says that the quality of a
champion goes far beyond the the chess
board that he should also be careful of
what he eats how he lives how he trains
in what shape does he keep his body how
he you know
where he goes where he hangs out and you
know pretty much everything describes a
champion not just the moves over the
board so Capablanca should really be
mindful of what he's doing and you know
not not catch a cold or the hunter than
go into bars and have a fight and that's
how law school rolls but okay if neither
player puts in an appearance at the time
appointed for play the clocks of the
players whose turn it is to move shall
be put into motion by the director of
play of the player whose turn it is to
move shall soria raising the same row
once again we put into motion by the
director of play or his substitute and
the game shall proceed capablanca says
okay but at least two times during the
match one should be excused without any
any evidence of why he's excused or
maybe it didn't say maybe he needed to
present some evidence but I mean okay it
really if someone stabs you you're not
supposed to lose the game so I guess it
makes sense and number 17 a code to be
agreed upon before the beginning of the
match all disputes concerning it while
it is in the making to be decided by an
umpire kappa blanka says that he has no
problems with this but as the last card
firmly stood his ground he did not not
on the on the points that capablanca can
win one game and draw the 29 other games
and that he will be world champion here
he would not simply not you know
go I don't know how to put it he would
not fold and also he was not interested
in playing at 15 moves per hour so
Callaspo was firmly set on this
capablanca needs to win by a two-point
margin or in a case that he wins four
games last score three and okay other 23
games can be drawn in this case
Capablanca becomes champion and we play
12 moves per hour those were the most
critical points of negotiations and then
Capablanca really went all out and in
Lasker's words he offended lost car in a
public letter little kappa blanka said
that alaska is his all the goes to a
state of obvious unfairness where he
accepts the challenge
but then he hides himself in terms that
are simply unacceptable by Capablanca or
by any other challenger and thus in
capablanca zeiss Alaska is no longer
champion
that's how kappa blanka puts it conv
lanka even published an article in his
Cuban article where he says that what he
put all of the champions or or all the
players that hold the titles and he put
Lasker's and endear of holding the title
in 1912 so basically capablanca said
that Alaska is no longer world chess
champion
yeah but outside of Cuba no the other I
mean the rest of the world wasn't really
interested in stripping loss core of the
title without a fair fight so like a
couple blanca had a legal representative
then we have the appearance of walter
pan Shipley we also talked about this
meandering capablanca match with Frank
James Marshall Frank a water pan Shipley
was known as as an arbitrator between
disputes and as a chief arbiter of
matches and well a lot of people knew
about him and he wrote both Alaska and
Capablanca saying to them that if they
wish so he would become arbiter of this
negotiations and but only if both last
round kappa blanka agreed that Waltrip
and Shipley once he makes his decision
that decision is final and no disputes
can be made unless both capablanca and
Lasker
agree on a term that would be changed
but so far none of that ever happened
and the capablanca pretty much gave up
on negotiations Alaska said that
negotiations also are over and that
Alaska is now interested in taking up
negotiations with Rubinstein because the
Rubenstein also issued a challenge to
dr. Emmanuel Lasker and acaba Blanca
filed a formal protest to both trip and
Shipley saying that last we cannot go
into negotiations with Rubenstein before
their negotiations are finished and then
Alaska also wrote to Walter pan Shipley
saying that is is it is it his duty as a
real champion to continue negotiations
with Capablanca even though they cannot
come to terms
in the meanwhile there was a Congress in
Cuba that they decided to organize the
biggest chess tournament ever held they
would call up
similarly in like in the 1911 tournament
of San Sebastiano where a players were
invited that have won big international
tournaments or have won second places in
two or three international tournaments
similar would be the the type of
invitation that would be received in
this a two-legged tournament won one leg
of the tournament will be played in New
York the second part in Havana and it
would be considered that the winner of
such such a tournament would be
proclaimed World Chess Champion and
Lasker replied to this and he said that
he was definitely interested in such an
event no problem he doesn't have to play
a match for the title of world chess
champion but he also had some terms and
he said that it wouldn't be fair if such
an event would be held in in Cuba Havana
at least one leg of the match a one leg
of the tournament because it's a couple
Blancas homeland he would have
home-field advantage and also Alaska
requested five and half thousand dollars
for him to even appear there as it would
be inconvenient for him to spend his own
money on traveling in stay there as he
still is considered by himself and by
the public World Chess Champion but yeah
such a such a thing never happened
because none of the players actually
went to the tournament and the entire
idea of this tournament was abandoned
and the negotiations haven't continued
between Alaska and Capablanca there were
talks of negotiation between Rubenstein
and Alaska and even Rubenstein and
Lasker came to terms and they agreed to
a match it was a similar agreement to
this one but but a bit of a difference
it was a if if someone would win eight
games during the 30 games then that one
would be proclaimed winner it was not
six games like in couple Blancas case
and it was also considered to be a 30
game match if no one managed to get to
the eight wins but then it wouldn't be a
draw like in the in the case where
Alaska negotiated with Capablanca but
rather they would continue playing until
one player
wins the game but only up until four
games so basically the match can only
last for 34 games first part of the
match would be 30 games and then the
four games were if Rubinstein wins even
one game Rubinstein is the champion but
this is 1914 now and well you all know
what that means it will be the outbreak
of World War one so nothing will be
going on in the chess world or more much
in any other world you know aside from
from the war raging but before that some
three months before the World War one
outbreaks we have again a meeting
between josé raúl capablanca and dr.
emmanuel ask her they met in the 1914
tournament of sankt-petersburg
are considered to be one of the
strongest tournaments ever held also
some of the players very strong players
from the 9th 11th Sun Sebastiaan
tournament will be there like a keeper
of insulin dr. Mullen vidmar ho Cyril
Capablanca will also play in this
tournament Frank James Marshall will
play but also determined will feature
dr. Emmanuel Lasker and it will be truly
a clash to enjoy so that's basically it
for the negotiations no terms were
agreed upon but instead of that we are
going into the 1914 tournament of
sankt-petersburg
where it's really gonna be it's just
gonna be an awesome tournament then
unfortunately we will have to wait a bit
for the World War one to end and then we
will enter renegotiations between
capablanca and Lasker so for those of
you who have a lasted up until this long
and have enjoyed the this entire
negotiation saga I congratulate you
truly you are an excellent subscriber
and we I did prepare our reward for you
I knew I knew that you thought that
there would be no game shown as there
are no players on the left but I did
prepare a very short attend move
miniature by kappa blanka that is unlike
unlike any miniature you've ever seen
because it's actually not a miniature
but you'll see what I mean it's a game
from 1908 it was played in the Manhattan
chess club between capablanca and
Leonard Mayer kappa blanka played efore
and basically it's a rule opus without
wood
much else Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop b5
a6 Bishop a4 and Knight to f6 more
faeces offenses on the board
d4 we have Knight captures on e4 and
this is still to even today consider
standard theory d5 now attacking the
knight on c6 and not Knight to e7
capablanca captures on e5 and we have
now defy forcing the brush up to b3
Bishop to be 7 and now capablanca plays
d6 opening up a discovered attack here
from the bishop to the f7 pawn Conchas
opponent recaptures with the knight
defends the f7 pawn and kappa blanka
simple captures with the Queen Knight
captures on d6 and it was in this
position that couple Blancas opponents
resigned the game but what's funny about
this position is its couple monk as
opponent didn't really have to resign
here it's not a position you you should
be resigning of course if you capture
the Queen II as Bishop captures on f7 is
checkmate but if you don't capture the
Queen there is this Knight d5 move which
traps kappa Blancas Queen and here
capablanca wouldn't really have any
option but but the capture on d7 give up
give up give the the piece back and
enjoy the rest of the game Queen
captures Queen captures Knight capture
screen captures and here let's say
castles the material is completely equal
and the game continues
but coupling has opponent when he saw
Queen captures on d6 he was like oh my
god it's it's all over and he resigned
the game so it's a really cool miniature
which you can show to your friends you
know in a bar or in a library but it's
really not a miniature so so there have
it but yeah that's the short game but
these were the negotiations I do hope
you enjoyed that it's only a small
fraction of the negotiations I really
couldn't prepare everything as it's
simply too vast but if you're interested
to acquire a book by by Edward winter
it's just called Capablanca and it
really features everything about him
from every other book that ever
mentioned kappa blanka
everything is there and it's just a you
know a wonderful source of vast
knowledge so I would like to thank
Marcia London Jonathan Tolan solid
systems they
Tenorio and Oscar Cabrera for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check too on my previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon
going into the 1914 tournament of some
competitors work where you know all hell
will break loose
thank you all and I'll see you soon